welcome back all right
Greg's dead
he's tired of being so successful which
makes it surprising that he wrote
another book you might have heard it's
called the king of late night and it's
out right now
Tom you're supposed to say Greg is dead
tired of being so successful well I
but they laughed I wanted to milk the
laugh
sometimes see Greg is like editing my
interview of him since it'd be weird for
him to interview himself he asked me to
do it so we're going to talk about the
book king of late night Greg tell me how
thank you
thank you how did you become king of
Late Night with probably I'm guessing
about one-tenth of the budget of other
late night shows you know what's scary
is it tells them that they tells their
bosses they don't need that money which
is probably a terrible message it should
be we need that money but there was a
giant hole and uh you know how I love
filling those Tom I'm out there every
morning on the road filling potholes
jerks uh Greg I'm looking at some of the
pictures in here I see some family
pictures where did you get your sense of
humor oh I got it probably from my dad
had a stupid sense of humor so maybe but
my mom was sick she was just brutal so I
think I got it from her if you turn to
Paige uh where is it where is it where
is it this is great for TV by the way
just there's a lot of nudity in here but
there's a great picture there's Tom
shallou see what I I don't lie that's
really me Greg that is that is real I
don't lie about this there you are
shirtless you just come out of the lake
there's a lot of shirtless men in this
book I said yes I said oh I don't look
that bad shirtless and then I said oh
that's Larry Gatlin yeah there's a
picture of Larry Gatlin who can't who
stopped by my apartment and to use the
shower so weird Greg interesting the
original title for the book yes what was
it the original title of the book is
called the flip and it's because we were
seeing this thing happen in all parts of
the world like Republicans were starting
to sound like Democrats you were seeing
like Republicans becoming ants anti-war
you're seeing Democrats becoming
anti-speech they've they were they led
the Free Speech mood movement in the 70s
and you just started seeing that
everywhere I just saw another flip the
other day well obviously comedy it was
always the right were the people that
weren't funny and it was the left that
were hip and I wrote about this uh like
20 years ago for The Huffington Post and
I and I said my goal was to flip it so
we owned the comedy and they were the
people that were always unhappy this is
your hum this is your 10th book is it
yes this is my tenth book tenth book
does each book make more money than the
last one no not even close
the law of diminishing returns all right
people get sick of you I understand it
uh so myself so is the the contents the
inside of this book essentially is it
the flip or did you just decide to write
a whole new book what happened was I had
all these chapters on the flip I had
foreign policy I had the drugs I had all
the and then I realized the comedy one
really mattered the most and the show
and also the show was taking off so I
was writing this I was like going
there's a big story and then I never
called myself the king of late night
somebody else did and it just picked up
and it just it was driving people crazy
if you look at the cover you see every
single person that we beat uh some
people who don't have shows anymore and
it was like such a great idea so I
thought just call also you know what I
did I took a a I took a what if what do
you call it I took a page out of uh uh
Jesse Waters book now Jesse is very
self-referential yes you know how I
saved the world I said well if he could
save the world then I could do this oh
yeah so you kind of uh now do you want
to talk about the fact that you were
ambivalent or unsure about going nightly
yes I mean I can talk about that I uh I
uh didn't want to do it because I I've
already got a Target on my back and I
hate that you know being on the five and
you know uh um and I thought why do I
need more of that stress so I went and I
talked to this guy who's uh uh uh talk
show what's a talk show host his name
rhymes with schmemis schmiller yeah
anyway and he told me you're right Greg
you shouldn't do it you should like you
got a great gig relax you know you got
two shows you don't need to work too
hard you should be working less so
that's what I thought was great and so I
told the bosses at Fox I wasn't that
interested in doing a late night show
and then I decided to call Tucker
Tucker was like are you crazy
of course you have to do the shop
and that's why you're here
pretty good
who's the real Greg Gutfeld oh geez some
guy I killed in 73 took his identity oh
wait that was supposed to be a joke uh
what is that I thought you know
a question thought you know it's like a
weird awkward 60 Minutes type question
that you know I thought you were here
you want to see the real Greg Gutfeld
you did the first this is me on my 40th
birthday wow high on ecstasy love that
among other things
could you say something nice about your
fellow late night host now that you're
the king of late night
um we have the best we have the best
people on the show
I would say that you mean the people
that aren't on this show I'm talking
about your competitors do you keep
crushing in your book and all these
people that are at your feet in the book
sometimes they make me laugh okay but
not always
well as you enter the pantheon of Great
American Authors uh I was already there
do you have any do you have any any
other books that you would recommend you
know that you would pick up if you go to
the bookstore and you pick up your book
any other books are you just like trying
to burn up some time here look I've got
a lot of questions here Greg that you
provided me with all right
oh you should go look at my back catalog
so look at my back catalog because I the
joy of hate is a great book it
chronicled uh cancel culture before they
had a name for it and they get all the
books at G gotfell.com right yeah which
brings me to this the promo before we go
quick reminder you can still get tickets
for Greg's book tour I'll be there too
we're doing a virtual event this
Thursday and we'll be in Providence
Rhode Island on the 29th and Reading
Pennsylvania on September 16th go to
gcutfeld.com for info and up next a
felonious Southern southern belle whose
photographs look well
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else